this video we'll talk about apoptosis
and this topic is for USMLE step one it
comes under pathology it's a high heel
topic watch the video till the end
so key points associated with apoptosis
it's a ATP dependent programmed cell
death so it has intricate signaling
details that program the process of cell
death
second intrinsic and extrinsic pathways
are two different Pathways that might
lead to the apoptosis but each of these
pathway converge at a caspase cleavage
event we'll talk about these Pathways in
the letter half
third characteristic is the
overall histological appearance of a
apoptotic cell so the eosinophilic
cytoplasm and the basophilic nucleus is
a characteristics of apoptotic cell
there are other characteristics like
pignosis and carrier axis
so pignosis means condensation of the
genome or the chromatins too much and
it's basically making the nucleus
non-functional and carioexis means a
advanced stage of nuclear dissolution so
nucleus gets fragmented into small
condensed half and gets scattered all
over the place that is called carrier
axis
so overall there would be cellular
breakdown cell shrinkage chromatin
condensation membrane bleming formation
of apoptotic bodies which would be
phagocytosed by immune cells
one of the Hallmark of apoptosis it
doesn't lead to any inflammatory
reactions all of these blobs are
actually taken by immune cells and
everything would be like taken care of
no inflammation in the area which is
very different
from the necrosis
anyway the cell membrane in case of
apoptotic cell remains pretty intact
whereas in a necrotic cell cell membrane
Integrity is compromised
but in apoptosis cell membrane
composition change most notably
phosphate phosphatidyl serine which is
remaining in the inner leaflet of the
normal viable cell moves to the outer
side when the cell is undergoing
apoptosis and that's a Hallmark feature
to distinguish normal cell versus
apoptotic Cell even if the cell is in
early apoptotic stage it can be
distinguished like this
the seventh point is the DNA lettering
so DNA gets fragmented with the action
of dnas so there would be like 180 to
200 base pair of DNA fragments all over
the place so these are Hallmark cellular
features of apoptosis now let's talk
about the pathways of apoptosis there
could be two distinct Pathways one
pathway is intrinsic another is
extrinsic intrinsic pathway uh is
basically involving mitochondria whereas
extrinsic pathway does not involve
mitochondria
extrinsic pathway involves specific
receptor ligand interaction which would
be clear in a moment so for example
there are tnf receptors fast and Fast
ligands which can mediate extrinsic
pathway
this triggers the initiator caspase
activation caspase are protein which are
getting cleaved to form a active caspase
now these initiator caspase does not do
the job its job is to further cleave and
activate Downstream executor caspet so
executor caspase is caspase 3 this
information is really important
so many cases can start the Cascade but
the nail in the coffin is the cleaved
caspase 3 this is the executor caspase
in active clipped caspase 3 get cleaved
into cleaved caspase 3 and eventually
caspers can degrade the DNA fragment the
nucleus and many other things it can
activate plethora of other enzymes and
proteases which can kill the cell okay
the intrinsic pathway uh starts with
sensing some kind of damage so the
intrinsic pathway can be triggered by
let's say a irreversible DNA damage
or let's say UV mediated damage anyway
there are BCL family sensors which can
sense this damage and there are
effectors such as backs and bad which
can poke holes in the mitochondrial
membrane
so when mitochondrial membrane Integrity
is compromised cytochrome C is released
in the cytoplasm generally it is never
expected to be in the cytoplasm right
now it's in cytoplasm and there are
specific enzymes such as apaf1 interacts
with the cytochrome c eventually with
help of other caspases It ultimately
activates the
cleaved caspase 3. clipped caspase 3
lead to all of the DNA cleavage and
breakdown of many other cellular enzymes
anyway bcl2 BCL excels these are other
bcl2 family proteins which can prevent
The Backs activity and thereby promoting
cell proliferation so it's a
anti-apoptotic factor
by the way after the cleavage of DNA
there are blibs which starts moving out
of the cell this might have fragmented
organelles it might have fragmented
genome and eventually these apoptotic
blades would be taken up by immune cells
like this macrophage in this example and
this ensures no inflammation happens
okay so apoptosis can be involved in
pathology or even it can be
physiological so during development
apoptosis work like a molecular
sculpture artist apoptosis occurs during
the digit individualization in our hand
during our developmental process so it's
a good thing
it also occurs
um
when you have like some kind of like a
proliferation queue when it is removed
apoptosis can occur an example can be
drawn from the immune system
the effector T cells can fight pathogens
and let's say their job is done they
eliminated the pathogen now there is no
point of keeping these effector cells
specific to that one particular pathogen
and il2 is that trigger Factor when il2
level goes down these cells are actually
eliminated
by apoptosis now there could be other
trigger for apoptosis like trauma
radiation or toxin all of these can lead
to apoptosis and these are obnoxious or
injurious stimuli so it is kind of like
pathology Associated as well
okay there could be symptoms which are
associated with apoptosis or problems in
apoptosis apoptosis is damn important
and when it doesn't happen because in
one case which is known as autoimmune uh
lymphoproliferative syndrome where the
fast ill and fast
interaction is abrogated and as a result
they are the clonal deletion of specific
reactive lymphocytes
this process is failed
so there are too many self-reacting
lymphocytes which results in
lymphadenopathy and many autoimmune
related complications that means
elimination of several cell types via
apoptosis is super important for normal
physiology
I hope this was informative if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up you
can follow us on Instagram Facebook and
Twitter you can get many notes displayed
like this in our Instagram and Facebook
page support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via paytm PayPal and
UPI see you next video